when it comes to dating
and relationships is it possible to have
a
pattern of picking the wrong guys
or women i think there's a lot of us
that can agree
this can be a pattern and so today we're
going to break it all
down and finding out how to
break the cycle one of my favorite
segments
of picking the wrong guys or women but
first
here's teresa's story check it out i'm
teresa roca
i'm 36 years old and i am from los
angeles california
but currently live in denver as long as
i can remember i have always picked the
wrong guys
i like to think i'm perfect but i know
that i'm not
so i'm recently single i have had my
fair share of long-term relationships i
was married
and divorced the checklist for me for my
ideal guy
is confidence but not cocky
adventurous and fun great sense of humor
and financially responsible those are my
four non-negotiables
i use my fair share of apps i'm
currently on a pause
i felt like everybody i was swiping
through they might look good on paper
but as soon as i started chatting with
them it was a no-go
and it was exhausting and time-consuming
and i just felt like it was going
nowhere i'm 36 years old
so i don't have forever everybody i
date is just the wrong guy he's not
right for me
i need somebody right for me i need help
breaking the cycle of picking the wrong
guy well please welcome to the show
theresa hello
hi crew thank you so much for having me
on i'm so excited
oh my goodness i had so many thoughts
and feelings
uh when i was watching your tape
and i guess first off why do you think
that you have a pattern of picking the
wrong guys you know i was married for
five years
and right after that i jumped into a
three-year relationship
and he was the complete opposite
of my husband and so i tried to like
counteract
what i had not liked from my previous
relationships
and you know since then i have met guys
that
only want to play video games all day or
they're not financially responsible
and all of these things are just they're
non-negotiables for me
i really loved your checklist i mean who
doesn't want that list
that that sounds totally on point to me
of course my list when i was younger was
like
messy unavailable full of drama and hot
as hell
so my list would be much more
in keeping with where your list is at
right now well it's true
um so that's sort of
that is not raising a ton of red flags
for me and
why is now the time that
you want to break the cycle well i'm 36
years old now
and i feel like all i've done for the
last 10 years is just waste time
waste time with the wrong guys and
you know i there there's a stigma with
women
rounding 40. i hate to say it but i feel
like there is
of you know you're not doing life right
you're you're not married you're not
you don't have kids you're you're not
doing it right
and i think i mean i think it's a bit
unfair but i also
feel that i am 36 and i would like to
stop wasting time and i would like to
find
my person and be able to you know
continue life and do the things that i
love to do
and possibly start a family you know 36
it's time well that was going to be my
question
uh if i may ask you a personal one which
is do you want to have children
yeah i definitely i don't necessarily
want five children
but especially in the recent years i've
been thinking more and more about
children
and one or two children in my life i i
just that's how i see myself
and i you know i i'm 36
so i i don't have forever i know that i
know that i've got time but i don't feel
like i have forever
so fantastic i have a lot to say on this
but i want to bring someone in
who will be able to help she's
extremely credentialed really brilliant
licensed psychotherapist and
relationship
expert dr tiffany davis henry
hi dr tim hi hi how are you guys
dr tiff i'm really excited to be working
with you on this segment
and i'm really excited to hear from you
what do you think about teresa's
a path her journey her past present
future
um what are your thoughts well i think
it's highly common drew i mean i think
all of us and you stated this too all of
us have kind of like picked some duds
over the top of the course of our
relationship history
so it's very common for most of us to go
through a phase of like bad
relationships or picking the wrong
guy or girl um so we come up with
and this is what teresa's done she's
come up with a list oh i don't want this
anymore and i don't want that anymore
after those relationships but the truth
is
that she can check all of those boxes on
her list
and the guy still be a jerk you know so
the list
isn't necessarily the thing that's going
to win her
her mr or mrs right
now teresa wants to have children
and at 36 years old the unfair
but true to life ticking clock really
kicks in
now have you considered freezing eggs
people put money in a bank why not put
eggs on reserve so is that something
that you would ever consider
yeah absolutely i mean i think that it's
it's kind of like an insurance policy
right
yeah i mean i i don't think there's
anything wrong with it i don't think it
makes
i i think it makes complete sense and
i'm the type of person i'm very
independent that
if i decide a couple years down the road
that i want to have a child i would
absolutely do it on my own yes i always
say
i know there's a plan a but it is so
great to make the plan b
so exciting that it rivals plan a
absolutely all right there is so much
more
to discuss
you